pour le prouver la reprise de l'économie
chinoise se fait sentir dans cette pme
située en banlieue de montréal
après l'incertitude sur les
approvisionnements de sacs en plastique
recyclé la confiance retrouvée onu d'un
retard qui était été primés l'orateur a
été pas mal comble étant donné que les é
nor commencé lors comme je dis là à la
fin de l'été de reprendre leur business
as usual
l'absence officielle d'une deuxième
vague de kobe 19 en chine a permis la
relance de la seconde économie mondiale
d'autres ont contracté sur deux selon le
bureau national des statistiques chinois
la production industrielle a augmenté de
près de 7% en septembre par rapport à
l'an dernier les exportations sont aussi
en hausse tant qu'acquis de paris des
pays occidentaux
on a obligé à ralentir à tous dans nos
productions rencontrent nos besoins
demeurent fragiles
si vous regardez les statistiques au
sujet des exportations chinoises
on va en fait exportations chinoises ont
même augmenté durant cette période les
verts marché à mika marqué tous et
confie qu'elle importe à entre les deux
pays
mais j'ai besoin seul mec sa part sur le
bateau les entrepreneurs doivent donc
composer avec deux plus longs délais de
livraison en raison de la forte demande
mondiale
une autre réalité les frappe durement
l'augmentation des coûts de fabrication
de plusieurs produits qu'ils achètent en
chine nous nos sacs sont faites dans la
même matière contre un pour les masques
jetables à usage unique
et puis pour les blues de désolation
donc cette macabre amiens laon est en
demande ça fait grimper les prix
on parle d'une augmentation de près de
50% dans les prix de la matière première
mais reprise économique ne signifie pas
un retour complet à la normale
les chinois ne dépensent plus au même
rythme qu'avant la pandémie chine et de
troubles majeurs
les gens ont encore peur dit ce
propriétaire de quelques magasins à one
il n'arrive plus à tous les loups et la
reprise économique permettent au parti
communiste chinois de déclarer que la
victoire complète contre la pauvreté
extrême promises d'ici la fin de l'année
ne sera pas retardée par la pandémie
dans son polo le président chinois se
présente même comme le champion de la
réduction de la pauvreté mondiale la
légitimité de l'autorité chinoise
actuelle repose essentiellement sur les
résultats économiques et sur laquelle tu
vas en matière aussi entre autres parce
que la lutte contre la pauvreté demeure
un des défis les plus pressants de la
chine reprise économique fulgurante ou
non il si philippe leblanc radio canada
toronto